vivre un rêve éveillé en admirant ses
toiles c'est l'idée des peintures d'éric
aux fontaines l'artiste des
clayes-sous-bois propose aux spectateurs
de voyager s'évader sortir de ce
contexte sanitaire un élément essentiel
aussi pour l'artiste plus on essaye de
l'enfermer plus il va s'évader pluie il
va tenter de raconter d'autres choses et
d'emmener les gens ailleurs parce que je
pense que on voit bien en ce moment
qu'une société qui est privé de culture
elle devient extrêmement triste voilà
monarque un tableau réalisé en 2020 la
rencontre entre les jardins du château
de versailles est une jungle un espèce
déco à
cette période qu'on traverse ou
comment réagit de la nature est ce que
la nature va reprendre ses droits dans
certains endroits et sert à quoi formée
aux beaux-arts de saint-etienne eric
roux fontaine a été directeur artistique
dans des agences de communication depuis
23 ans maintenant il est peintre 100% de
son temps avec près de huit cents toiles
à son actif pour construire ses oeuvres
le peintre que les siens à une palette
de sources d'inspiration ses voyages en
inde ou au costa rica et ses
photographies quand je suis en voyage je
fais énormément de croquis ge j'écris je
fais des photographies etc tout ça c'est
une sorte de matière brute ensuite je
rentre dans l'atelier
le second mouvement je l'appelle tamiser
le monde c'est à dire que je vais faire
des tirages comme ça brut de
photographies qui sont comme des petites
notes d'instants de forme de lumière
puis une étape intermédiaire est
nécessaire pour passer de la
photographie au tableau quand on rêve à
quelque chose on a pâli des déchets l'on
n'a pas les des proportions n'a que la
sensation
donc je pars toujours de cette sensation
est ensuite j'essaie de construire
physiquement une image et pour découvrir
le travail d'éric roux fontaine
plusieurs tableaux sont exposés à la
galerie felli à paris jusqu'au 29
janvier 2021
[Musique]